what we're going to cover in this video
is the intermediate value theorem which
despite some of this math II language
you'll see is one of the more intuitive
theorems possibly the most intuitive
theorem you will come across in a lot of
your mathematical career so first I'll
just read it out and then I'll interpret
it and hopefully we'll all appreciate
that it's pretty obvious I'm not going
to prove it here but I think the
conceptual underpinning
so the theorem tells us that suppose F
is a function continuous at every point
of the interval the closed interval so
we're including a and B so it's
continuous at every point of the
interval a B and so let me just draw a
couple of examples of what F could look
like just based on these first line so
suppose F is a function continuous at
every point of the interval a B so let
me draw some axes here so that's my
that's my y axis and this is my x axis
so one situation if this is a and this
is B F is continuous at every point of
the interrupted interval a and B so that
means it's got to be for sure defined at
every point as well as B continues to be
continuous you have to be defined at
every point and the limit as u are the
limit of the function as you approach
that point should be equal to the value
of the function of that point and so the
function is definitely going to be
defined at f of a so it's definitely
going to have an f of a right over here
this right over here is f of a maybe F
of B is higher although we can look at
different cases so that would be our F
of B and they tell us it is a continuous
function it is a continuous function so
if you're trying to imagine continuous
functions one way to think about it is
if we're continuous over an interval we
take the value of the function at one
point of the interval and if it's
continuous we need to be able to get to
the other the the value of the function
at the other point of the interval
without picking up our pencil so
I can do all sorts of things it's to be
a function so I can't I can't do
something like that but as long as I
don't pick up my pencil this is a
continuous function so there you go if I
had to if I if I if the somehow the
graph I had to pick up my pencil if I
had to do something like this oops I got
to pick up my pencil to do something
like that well it's not continuous
anymore if I had to do something like
this and hoops pick up my pencil not
continuous anymore if I had to do
something like woop okay pick up my
pencil go down here not continuous
anymore so this is what a continuous
function that a function that is
continuous over the closed interval a B
looks like I can draw some other
examples in fact let me do that so let
me draw one maybe where f of B is less
than F of a so it's my y-axis then this
is my x-axis and once again a and B
don't both have to be positive they
could both be negative one could be a
could be negative B could be positive
and maybe in this situation and F of a
and F of B it could also be positive or
negative but let's take a situation
where this is f of a so that right over
there is f of a this right over here is
f of B f of B and once again we're
saying f is a continuous function so I
should be able to go from F of A to F be
F of B draw a function without having to
pick up my pencil so it could do
something like this actually I want to
make it go vertical it could go like
this and then go down and then do
something like that so these are both
cases and I could draw an infinite
number of cases where f is a function
continuous at every point of the
interval the closed interval from A to B
now given that there's two ways to state
the conclusion for the intermediate
value theorem you'll see it written in
one of these ways or something close to
one of these ways and that's why I
included both of these so one way to say
it is well if the this first statement
is true then F will take on every value
between F of a
and F of B over the interval and you see
in both of these cases every interval
for every every value between F of a and
F of B so every value here is being
taken on at some point you can pick some
value you could pick some value in
arbitrary value L right over here well
look L happened right over there
if you pick L well L happened right over
there and actually it also happened
there and it also happened there and the
second bullet point describes the
intermediate value theorem or in that
way for any L between the values of F of
a and F of B there exists the number C
in the closed interval from A to B for
which f of C equals L so there exists at
least one C so in this case that would
be our C over here there's potential
there's multiple candidates for C that
could be a candidate for C that could be
the C so we could say there is there
exists at least one number at least one
number I'll throw that in there at least
one number C in the interval for which
this is true and you know something that
might amuse you for a few minutes is try
to draw a function where this first
statement is true but somehow the second
statement is not true
so you say okay well let's say is let's
assume that there's an L where there
isn't two C in the interval well let me
let me try to do that I'll draw it and
I'll draw it big so that we can really
see how obvious that we have to take on
all of the values between F of a and F
of B is so let me draw a big axis this
time so that's my y-axis and that is my
x-axis and I'll just do the case where
just for simplicity that is a and that
is B and let's say that this is f of a
so that is f of a and let's say that
this is f of B the dotted line alright F
of B and we assume
that we we have a continuous function
here so the graph I could draw it from f
of A to F of B from this point to this
point without picking up my pencil from
this coordinate a comma F of a to this
coordinate B comma F of B without
picking up my pencil well let's let's
assume that there is some L that we
don't take on let's say there's some
value L right over here and and we never
take on this value this continuous
function never takes on this value as we
go from X equaling a to X equal B let's
see if I can draw that let's see if I
can get from here to here without ever
essentially crossing this dotted line
well let's see I could let maybe I'll
avoid it a little bit I'll avoid but up
G how am I going to get there well
without picking up my pencil well well I
really need to cross that line all right
well there you go I found we took on the
value L and it happened at C which is in
that closed interval so once again I'm
not giving you a proof here but
hopefully you have a good into intuition
that the intermediate value theorem is
it's kind of common sense the key is
you're dealing with a continuous
function if you were making its graph if
you were to draw it between the
coordinates a comma f of a and B comma F
of B and you don't pick up your pencil
which would be true of a continuous
function well it's going to take on
every value between F of a and F of B